this our is Fred and Dallas hi Fred how
are you good
you know better than I deserve how can I
help sir yes we are the proud owners of
a dead-end
construction company and we're selling
that selling our house and trying to pay
down all of our debts rapelling proud
owner was a sarcasm yes okay I got you
so anyway we're hoping to pay down all
but maybe thirty thousand of our debt
okay and the question is moving forward
I've got it I've landed a job okay and
but with selling our home we're going to
need a thinking of living in an RV
because my job will be traveling and
possibly have needing to buy a new truck
so that's work roadworthy my question is
by paying down this debt is it a wise
thing to do a little bit of debt to go
forward like I said because there's
going to be travel involved and so just
the cheap car is going to work so you're
gonna sell your home and go on the road
and how many kids do you have 3 ok this
is sounding less fun every moment what
kind of a job are you taking
construction superintendent okay and so
you're going to be in a city for how
long probably three four weeks no sorry
eight to nine weeks and then and how
many different cities does are they all
different want every single anywhere
from Washington to Florida so everywhere
okay correct so that's why I say you
know you know I have a truck now that
I'm working at selling but I don't know
that it's that weird
worthy what is in county miles are on
that truck 250,000 it's not real Road
worthy okay all right what do you I
guess my question is going from two
hundred and twenty five thousand in debt
seventy is that a is that a good step or
well I'm that you know I I think some
kind of a truck to get by them very
minimal truck to get buys is going to be
an idea here trying to think through the
best way to service this though
because I the way I answer questions on
this show is what would I do if I were
in your shoes and I can't see us loading
up three kids living in an RV so I I
wouldn't I personally wouldn't do that
so it's hard for me to get my head
around asking you to do it or being okay
with you doing it because I'm a you
sound awfully desperate is what I'm
hearing you took a good job that pays
well because your construction company's
going down and you're getting rid of it
I got that part right
you're a responsible man thank you for
being a good husband and a good dad now
packing them up and putting them in the
RV and heading off to Beverly I don't
know about that part I'm wondering if
you don't need the home you're selling
is how much in debt it's about ninety
and I really those things so you can get
about a hundred and eighty for it and
that's going to clean up a whole bunch
of your mess then yes okay so let's try
this for six months and then if you want
to change your plan change it if I were
in your shoes I would rent something for
my family to stay in there in the town
that they're used to living in or near
family if you want to move them that's
fine as their family in your area yes
how long have you lived there
you're about nine years okay and so you
got you got some social routes
Church whatever family support for the
kids and wife and you commute for six
months and let's come in on the weekends
and take your truck to the site and
drive it for the seat
we trade weaker at each site and let's
just do it dad travels for a living
thing and let's not uproot the whole
freaking family even if they're okay
with that yeah I know I mean it sounds
like an adventure for the first 20
minutes you just put three kids in an RV
dude yeah it's just I mean you can do it
if you want to do it is your decision
I'm just I am bound by you know being
being honest enough to say I personally
can't get my head around doing that so
I'm having trouble telling you to do it
and and and the other part of that is
there there's a per diem per per week
yes I think that my family could live on
in that RV yeah which you could live on
you know in a decent you know corporate
type cheaper hotel the corporate hotel
things that most people that do what
you're talking about doing do very few
people run around the country as
construction supers lots of people run
around the countries Construction supers
but very few of them do it with an RV in
tow with their family in it most of them
are running and then I corporate hotels
and and then they run back home on the
weekends and you know you get you can
you got your mess cleaned up your family
can kind of get healed from all the debt
and the the process you've gone through
closing your business and all that stuff
which is hard on you and you kind of get
your emotions back together and six
months later if the RV thing still
sounds fine and fun and you all want to
do it I'm not gonna be mad at you for
doing it I'm not imagine we're doing it
today
I just just a little bit afraid of it it
number one an RV is a very large
purchase that goes down in value the
worst of any possible thing there
absolutely horrendous I mean they make
boats and airplanes look smart neither
one of which are smart financially okay
but I mean they go sound value so fast
I've got boats I'm not mad you know it's
okay but but the thing is just man
you're gonna get stuck again in that
thing yeah well that's what I'm afraid
of and that's why I call it in so so I
mean that that's just what's bothering
me about it so I always like to trot up
your you know you changed careers
you're changing housing
and your your you're going through this
process of gutting your life kind of and
you're going all the way over to the
edge of the pendulum swing and I'd like
to come back in about two notches and
kind of give your family a break a
little bit and then six months will go
by fast I mean after the first of the
year
if everybody still wants to live in an
RV and you've gotten stabilized and you
want to go do that then go do it
but I would try to tap the brakes a
little bit and no pun intended and and
and let's just let sanity return to your
life and see if that still looks smart
after sanity returns you got stuff you
got so many variables flying around your
head right now it looks like a cartoon
with the blue birds flying around your
head you know and that's just how it
feels talking to you I mean you do what
you want to do it I'll be I'll be here
to help you and back you either way but
I think the so in the house and cleaning
up all the debt making the new job those
are all smart things getting a basic
truck a real real real basic truck not
not not a $35,000 f-150 okay you don't
need that but something that you can get
over to that location and then come back
from there you know and you can commute
a little bit that's what I would do hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income or $500,000
in the cotton
you